so why would someone get heart
palpitations after they eat let's talk
about that first of all what is the
palpitation
it's a skipped beat it could be an extra
beat as well you also have PVCs and pa
CS this stands for premature ventricular
contractions or premature atrial
contractions you don't need to know that
all you need to know is both of these
are extra abnormal beats that can occur
a palpitation is an irregular heartbeat
it's a sensation that you feel in the
chest area like a flip-flop or something
that starts and stops and it has to do
with your heart pacemaker it's called a
cardiac pacemaker a pacemaker is a group
of cells that are automatically
programmed to keep the heart and rhythm
an average person at rest normally has a
heartbeat of 70 70 beats per minute and
what's happening is you're getting this
rhythmic electrical impulse that causes
the heart to contract which pushes the
blood through the lungs to get oxygen
carries it through the body gives oxygen
to the cells which comes back through
the other side of the heart and the
whole cycle starts over again at the
cellular level you're getting this
exchange with different electrolytes
okay which are electrically charged
minerals like potassium and sodium and
magnesium and chloride and calcium and
you have these little tiny pumps that
are made of protein that are pumping in
and out of the cells at a very very fast
rate like a thousand per second these
different electrolytes and what causes
the electrolytes to travel are the
difference in electrical charge the
difference in pH and the difference in
concentration of certain minerals and on
top of that you have a part of the
nervous system called the autonomic
nervous system so it's a bit complex so
let's just get into what causes
palpitations and by the way palpitations
skip heart beats are a precursor for a
more serious problem like atrial
fibrillation and other more it
Vance problems with the rhythm of the
heartbeat but let's get into the main
causes and the ones that are more common
than others the big one is digestion
when I was in practice there's so many
people that came in with palpitations
and digestive problems and I'm talking
about heartburn acid reflux GERD and
gall bladder issues and that could be
burping belching bloating gall stones
sludge in the gall bladder and a lot of
those cases had complications so what is
the connection well we don't exactly
know but it's probably the pressure
that's occurring inside the bile ducts
and a lot of times when you have a gall
bladder problem you have a buildup of
pressure somewhere in the tubes between
the liver and the gallbladder or the
liver and the small intestine and when
that pressure builds up it can create a
lot of soft tissue guarding and tension
and spasm around the area and because
the bile ducts and the gallbladder are
so closely connected to the
cardiovascular system that pressure can
then affect the heart and cause these
palpitations I'm going to talk about
what to do about that in a little bit
but let's go to number two low potassium
this is probably one of the top causes
as well
why because potassium is the main
electrolyte that controls the pacemaker
and if you're low in potassium the risks
go up for you getting palpitations and
other problems even atrial fibrillation
which is a more advanced version of that
number three let's say your pH is too
alkaline and what I'm talking about
alkaline I'm talking about when the pH
goes higher okay the lower you get the
more acidic things are if the blood pH
which normally should be between seven
point three five and seven point four
five goes above seven point four or five
even a little bit your body is now
excessively alkaline it's called
alkalosis that occurs the minerals
specifically potassium doesn't move that
well through the body through the heart
so if your pH is too alkaline that could
be the cause and before caffeine too
much caffeine can cause this problem to
which alcohol a hyper thyroid condition
I'm not gonna focus on these right here
I want to focus on these two right here
which are the more common let's take a
look at that right now all right so if
you have digestive problems whether
bloating heartburn GERD acid reflux I
put some links down below so you can get
a lot more information on what to do
about it
but the simple thing to do would be to
start doing in a minute fasting for
those of you that are new to my channel
I put a link down below if you're not
new to my channel you know what a minute
fasting is because that is the most
powerful thing that you can do to take
the pressure off the digestive system
and let the digestive system actually
reset and heal especially the
gallbladder you also need to avoid
refined carbohydrates and vegetable oils
like in soy oil in corn oil these two
types of so-called foods are very very
hard on the gallbladder and the stomach
and they're highly associated with
causing that pressure build up in those
tubes simple thing to do would be do
healthy ki tale put a link down below
for those of you that don't know what
that is
that will help the digestion and that
will decrease the risk of getting these
palpitations alright number two
alkalinity if you have low potassium
that could be the cause of your body
being too alkaline if you have high
cortisol if you're too stressed out that
could be the reason why your body is too
alkaline I know a lot of people are
trying to alkalize the body because they
think they're too acid and that might be
the case but there's also another
problem of being too alkaline and that
will affect the minerals especially
potassium I put a link down below if
you're confused on that so you can
understand pH also low hydrochloric acid
okay like in your stomach that can
create a problem with your pH as well in
which case you want to start consuming
apple cider vinegar some
through the diet if you do a combination
of healthy keto like I'm recommending
for this I always recommend apple cider
vinegar with that program so you should
kill two birds with one stone next thing
and this is very very common
you just have low potassium that's going
to set you up for this problem now why
are you low in potassium maybe you're on
a diuretic because you have high blood
pressure well guess what there's three
things that cause high blood pressure
one would be low potassium so in other
words the low potassium is causing the
high blood pressure which causes you to
take a diuretic which depletes your
potassium you see the problem there also
if you're low in vitamin D which a lot
of people are that can cause
hypertension and deplete your potassium
reserves and if you have high insulin
which the majority population has or you
have insulin resistance or you're
pre-diabetic that can cause a depletion
of potassium diarrhea that can also
deplete your potassium levels as well as
other electrolytes if you're on any
assets that can cause low potassium
because it takes a very strong acid
stomach to absorb these minerals thus
the outside of vinegar in your diet and
lastly let's say you're just not
consuming enough dietary potassium this
is very common why because you don't
consume enough vegetables it takes seven
to ten cups of vegetables to get close
to your daily amount of potassium that
your body needs so you need to up these
if you're having a hard time with this I
put a link down below of an electrolyte
powder that may help you as well all
right there you have it
the actual causes of palpitations after
you eat and when you're not eating as
well thanks for watching hey if you're
liking this content please subscribe now
and I will actually keep you updated on
future videos